we've just had another cop agreement
where the wealthier countries are
agreeing to send more money to Aid those
who need more assistance to tackle
climate change obviously for many people
they will see that as a great idea but
some of our viewers might be thinking
Hang on we're in a cost of living crisis
here at the minute our debt interest
payments are soaring can we really
afford to do this
well the detail is still coming in that
was obviously agreed overnight so we
need to look at that detail as we get
more information but of course the UK
through its overseas a budget has always
played a role in terms of tackling
climate change supporting countries
around the world in terms of the
measures they're taking so we need to
look at whatever's been agreed in The
Wider context of our International Aid
package and now I want to talk to you
about the NHS there's lots I want to
talk to you on that however before we do
and the Sunday Times is reporting on
brexit that the government is
considering a Swiss style relationship
with the European union now that would
mean relatively frictionless trade but
it would also mean paying more money
into the EU budget and almost certainly
higher immigration plus an increased
role for the European courts of Justice
too
do you recognize these reports no I
don't and if you look at the Autumn
statement what the chancellor set out
was our determination to maximize the
brexit opportunities in hair growth
areas whether that's in green Industries
whether it's in life sciences whether in
financial services and in fact there
were specific announcements in the
Autumn statement in terms of solvency
too we've got a prime minister who
himself supported brexit I myself did
and was brexit secretary and worked very
hard to maximize our control of our laws
our borders and our money so it's
absolutely important that particularly
in those high growth sectors such as
Financial Services line sciences and the
green industries that we really use the
brexit freedoms we have and so I don't
recognize this story at all could you
ever support that kind of agreement well
I don't support that I want to maximize
the opportunities that brings it up
that's what I worked for as brexit
secretary and as the minister
responsible for Life Sciences I see huge
opportunities
for the UK and being agilely moving at
PACE and having a regulatory system that
is absolutely tailored to the the UK
needs at the same time you know Jeremy
Hunt has said that he wants to remove
the vast majority of trade barriers with
the EU I mean if you're really serious
about doing that then this is the kind
of thing you need to look at isn't it
well the point is it's in both sides
interests to remove barriers where we
traded with each other we're important
Partners to each other so that's
mutually beneficial and of course we
want to work constructively with EU
Partners to do that but that's not at
the expense of maximizing opportunities
in high growth sectors and the Autumn
statement uh singled our determination
to do that for example with the
announcement on solvency too um I just
want to talk about the Autumn statement
with regards to brexit because the
office of budget responsibility you know
the official independent Watchdog were
pretty clear on what they thought about
it they said that brexit will result in
the UK's trade intensity being 15 lower
in the long run than if the UK had
remained in the EU the latest evidence
suggests that brexit has had a
significant adverse impact on UK trade
um
and going on today via reducing both
overall trade volumes and the number of
trading relationships between UK and EU
firms do you accept that brexit has had
as the obr says a significant adverse
impact on UK trade well I think there's
dangers in looking at one little bit of
The Ledger in isolation if you look at
the vaccines roll out whilst technically
legally an EU member could have done
things differently I think culturally
the question would not have done so well
the question is do you accept brexit has
had a significant adverse impact on UK
trade well I think there's pros and cons
and the point is we have opportunities
we have opportunities through the
Divergence opportunities I've just
talked about things like solvency too to
get those Pension funds investing in
leveling up communities better
reflecting the needs of our financial
services specifically do you accept
brexit has had a significant adverse
impact on UK trade well what I'm saying
is you've got to look at the issues in
terms of brexit in the round there are
areas where there have been difficulties
in terms of Greater friction and we're
looking to work constructively with EU
Partners on that but equally there are
very significant opportunities as a
result of brexit I don't think we would
have done the vaccine rollout in the way
that we did had we remained a member of
the it sounds like and the significant
regulatory opportunities we have and the
Autumn statements signaled our
determination to take those you're clear
on what you see to be the kind of
positives the opportunities but do you
accept it has had a significant adverse
impact on trade what I'm saying is
there's pros and cons it's very hard
it's very specific it's very hard to
model exactly what the impact would be
for example we've just been through well
has done that haven't they of course
that I know from my time when I was
brexit secretary just how difficult it
is to model these things of course we've
been through a pandemic that has had an
impact there's a range of things well
the point is what matters is we maximize
the freedoms that we have uh take those
particularly into the high growth
sectors such as in Digital Life Sciences
green technologies and financial
services and the Autumn statements
signaled I'm intent to do so okay now I
do want to move on to the NHS such an
important issue many of our viewers will
be really concerned about it and if I
may I just want to play to you what
happened when our correspondent phrase
Ward went to Rochdale for this program
to ask people about their experiences of
the NHS
a lot of people going to a e because
they can't get doctors appointment so
then they um
working nine hours in a e which is
ridiculous I was a nurse and I do think
the standards gone down an awful lot
since I was nursing a lot could be done
to improve I think it's struggling it's
pushed for funding
um
you run to wait for appointments a lot
longer than you were before not enough
doctors they're waiting times are too
long I took my daughter there last week
we were sat in there for six and a half
hours more staff we need
better stuff the waiting times just for
everything is too long as far as the
doctor's surgeries goes I can't get an
appointment it's shocking at the moment
and I live in Milton raw and my doctor's
surgery
it can be on your last legs and you
can't get an appointment
what's your response to that well when
Jeremy Hunt and I were last in the
Department of Health four years ago we
put in place the biggest ever increase
in medical undergraduate training at 25
increase those doctors obviously take
time to come on stream they'll become
Junior doctors in 2024 so that gives an
indication of our commitment to boosting
numbers we've got three percent more
doctors this year than last year and
we're looking also at how we boost the
wider Primary Care stuff we had a
Manifesto commitment on that and we're
on track to deliver it but I recognize
as a consequence of the pandemic GP
appointments have been under pressure we
all see more people 90 000 more G
appointments this year than last year
we're looking at what technology we can
offer some things like Cloud telephony
so we avoid the ATM sort of scramble of
calls to a GP on a Monday morning so
it's about the technology we put in
place it's about the wider skills and
boosting those numbers in primary care
but it's also about boosting the numbers
of GPS and that's what we did by opening
five new medical schools where students
started in 2019 but obviously there's a
time lag in those coming on stream
they're talking about doctors there
they're also talking about a e and I
just want to show you the latest waiting
times graphic for a e and it's pretty
shocking you can see there this is the
number of patients waiting more than 12
hours in a e hitting over 43 000 in
October now I showed the same graph to
Jeremy Hunt when he was on the program
and I put it to him that you know this
looks like a Health Service on the brink
of collapse he said there are massive
pressures on the NHS and I think that
doctors and nurses on the front line are
frankly under unbearable pressure so I
do recognize the picture you say I mean
do you think the NHS is on the brink of
collapse well what that graph shows you
can see for example firstly that it's
very much driven by the pandemic in
terms of the the shoes
well let me come on to what the
situation yes and I recognize so I
recognize particularly for staff they're
under huge pressure in na nurses doctors
working for anomaly hard given what that
graph shows that is why in the Autumn
statement we prioritize in particular
social care 2.8 billion next year 4.7
billion at the year of after in 2024
we'll have 8 billion pounds going into
Health and Social care and the reason we
private prioritized both Health and
Social care is because of delayed
discharges
the key issue when you see that graph
the focus tends to be on a e or
ambulances what is causing that graph is
the Thirteen and a half thousand delayed
discharge which often links into social
care and that's why we've targeted
funding a very significant amount of
funding at a difficult time into social
care so we can tackle that delayed
discharge which ultimately is the way we
get the tones down just briefly because
you talked a lot about what you want to
do and I'll talk about your uh extra
decision making when it comes to
um cuangos or um files or the 10 pushes
of the mouth is putting it but before we
do do you accept there is a problem with
NHS right now that it's not acceptable
well except it's under huge pressure and
that's because of the pandemic let me
give you one example the the number of
52 weights for operations was 1 300
going into the pandemic it's now over
400 000. okay so this is because of the
pandemic we Face huge pressures that's
primarily the cause what we've done is
Target things like delayed discharge
which is the way we get flow into
hospitals which is critical for shifting
those numbers now the NHS got 3.3
billion pounds of extra funding in the
Autumn statement but according to the
men on Sunday you're calling for a
bonfire of the NHS pen pushers what does
that mean we've got 6.6 billion over two
years but it's important that we get
maximum value for money from that and if
I look for example at the center at the
Department of Health and its Armstrong
for what it is they collectively cost
2.8 billion pounds and I think the scope
is to look at what the costs are in
terms of administration in the NHS how
fewer targets devolve more decision
making we now have we now have the
integrated care boards that can look at
issues on a population basis a much more
localized basis what I want to do is
give more autonomy more freedom to trust
leaders to our icbs so that they're not
spending so much time managing upwards
which in the feedback they give to me is
a constant source of frustration for
them so let's have a more streamlined
Center developing or decision making to
those on the ground that's a better just
want to talk about targets because you
say that you want to cut hundreds of
targets but you know targets are the way
we monitor NHS performance right you
know the graph that we just showed on a
e waiting times that's how we know
there's an issue with a e it's frankly
how people like me can hold people like
you responsible is there not a place for
Targets in the NHS they're important
aren't they well there is a place for
targets but they've everything's a
priority nothing's a priority and risk
in my view is best assessed on a
population basis through the icbs by
local leaders they're better able to
tailor the priorities for the local
needs and we will have information such
as important right of course of course
and no one's suggesting we don't have
any Targets but what I'm saying is
there's a 2.8 billion pounds do you want
to get rid of the target such as any
waiting time no I think the a e is a
very useful Target in terms of actually
the wider system Health within the NHS
and it speaks to flow which is a key
issue in terms of ambulance under a days
and people waiting in a e now another
big issue for you is strikes the Royal
College of Nursing striking for the
first time in its history now you told
the Sunday Telegraph their demands are
unreasonable and unaffordable what would
be a reasonable pay rise there and
nurses well what they're asking for is
17.6 that would be an extra cost for
nine billion pounds on the NHS budget
that for your viewers it is around three
times more than those in outside the
public sector are receiving and that's
why I think that is unreasonable and of
course whilst pay is important it's
important to look at the package in the
round at the NHS contributes a fifth of
a nurse's salary into the pension with
their contribution on top that means a
quarter uh it goes into a nurse's
pension 33 days plus of annual leave so
it's important to look at the package as
around it would be reasonable pay rise
do you think nurses pay should keep up
with inflation well we have a process to
to answer that question which is the
independent
because you've just described their
demands as unreasonable and affordable
so we know you can give your opinion
well my opinion is we have a process
through the independent pay-per-view
body that is why last year nurses got
three percent when the rest of the
public sector had a pay freeze we have a
process through independent pay-per-view
body to look at these issues in the
round and of course Sophie it's not
simply about pay when I speak to nurses
but you also talk about the estate
that's why we're investing in 40 new
hospitals that's why we've got a
significant Capital program around the
surgical herbs the diagnostic Centers
it's also about technology one of the
big bears nurses tell me is often when
the tech actually makes their their job
difficult and and we haven't got the
right Tech in place so so it's not just
about hey it's about the wider
conditions and that's why I'm very keen
to engage with the Trade union as I saw
the General Secretary of Unison this
week I had a round table with Union news
I'm at the RCN also last week so my my
door is open we're engaging with the
trade unions there are other factors
alongside pay that we need to discuss
but we do have a process through the
independent pay-per-view body to look at
these issues now
um this week like so many of us I've
been really touched by the story of the
little boy Arab ishak you know the
two-year-old who died after he was
living in a moldy flat and we know of
course the boss of the housing provider
has resigned and
does the government need to look at
itself as well I mean how are we living
in a country where a two-year-old boy
can die from the housing that he's
living in well it's heartbreaking isn't
it and aside from being a minister I'm
also a parent you know I've got two
young children and I think anyone sort
of looks at that you know regardless
actually whether a parent or not but I
think just as Citizens we look at that
story and you know it's it's a terrible
story and it's clear that it needs to be
followed through we need to look at what
lessons there are clearly there were
fairies in terms of the way the local
Council acted I know it's something that
Michael and Michael Gove is taking a
very serious look at in a very
interested and it's uh it's something
that's heartbreaking for us all to see
do we need to really focus on housing at
the minute well I think we need more
housing we need to to boost that I think
that's important to intergenerational
fairness as well but I think boosting
housing is separate to what were clearly
some failures here where the family had
raised concerns and those were not acted
on and and we need to to look into that
finally World Cup starts today there's
been some concerns of course about
qatar's treatment of women the LGBT
community and also of course the migrant
workers many of whom were working on
these stadiums and yesterday there was
this extraordinary press conference from
the president of FIFA who said that the
one side side of morality lesson is just
hypocrisy and he said that Europe and
the West should be apologizing for what
we've been doing for 3000 Years Around
the World before giving moral lessons
what's your response to that uh well
it's an international uh major event and
I think all of us are excited we we
firstly wish the England team well and
also just on the subject as well a huge
shout out to everyone in rugby league I
think uh the tournament that they've
just had both the men's the women's the
wheelchair has been a fantastic showcase
for sports uh and for rugby league in
particular but obviously in terms of
Qatar it's important that we engage uh I
think everyone will want to get behind
uh the team and it's a major tournament
that we're very much looking forward to
I'm James cleverley the former secretary
said fan should respect the law of the
home country is it right I think people
should respect the law whether that's
overseas or in the UK even if you don't
agree with that we can go along with it
without respecting it well I think the
law of the land wherever you go it's
important to respect yes okay
um you're gonna be watching the World
Cup of course who's your money on to win
yeah well like you I think we all want
uh England to win and uh you know that's
what we're backing yeah I definitely
want England to win but I'm not sure
that's where my money would be going
I'll be honest thank you very much for
being on the program today